há 128 anos
o último país do planeta terminou com
escravidão negra
este país é o brasil e depois de todo
esse tempo a gente ainda vive num mundo
onde a cor da pele não só dá uma
primeira impressão mas uma última cheia
de significados que pesa
eu nasci em uma família cheia de cores
meu pai é filho de uma empregada
doméstica de quem herdou intenso tom de
chocolate
ele foi adotado por aqueles que eu
conheço como meus avós
a matriarca minha vó minha pele de
porcelana e o cabelo de algodão
meu avô era algo entre o guti de família
e morango como o meu tio e meu primo
minha mãe canela é filha de uma
brasileira mistura de avelã com mel e um
homem mistura de café com leite mas com
muito café
ela tem duas irmãs uma num tom amendoim
do estado ea outra bege
mais ou menos como pudim de leite
crescendo nessa família
a cor nunca foi importante pra mim mas
fora de casa
as coisas foram diferentes muito cedo a
cor tem muitos significados
eu lembro na minha primeira lição do
desenho como uma mistura de sentimentos
contraditórios e estava feliz super
emocionada
mas eu nunca entendi o único lápis de
cor pele porque eu tenho pele mas não
sou rosa minha cor é marrom e as pessoas
diziam que eu era negra
eu tinha 7 anos e uma bagunça de cores
na cabeça
anos depois quando levava meu primo a
escola as pessoas confundiam com a babá
ao ajudar na cozinha numa festa de um
amigo às vezes pensavam que eu era
empregada
eu fui inclusive tratada como uma
prostituta
só porque eu estava andando na praia
sozinha com os amigos europeus e muitas
vezes visitar a minha avó
os meus amigos em um edifício de alta
classe delicadamente eu era convidado a
utilizar o elevador de serviço porque
afinal com essa cor e com esse cabelo eu
não pertenço alguns lugares de alguma
maneira eu me acostumei e eu aceitei
é parte disso e ser tratado dessa
maneira mas alguma coisa aqui dentro de
mim e resolvia e estava incomodada anos
depois eu me casei com o espanhol mas
não foi o espanhol qualquer não eu
escolhi um do tipo que fica com o
camarão quando toma o primeiro raio do
sol
depois disso uma nova pergunta começou a
me perseguir
qual vai ser a cor do meu filho como
vocês podem entender a minha última
preocupação mas pensando nisso estando
fora daqui pra de verdade poder olhar e
aceitar quem eu era
minha história pessoal me levou a fazer
um projeto fotográfico e foi assim que
uma mãe nasceu humanae é uma tentativa
de reflexionar e mostrar as nossas
verdadeiras cores em vez do branco
vermelho preto e amarelo associados a
raça é uma espécie de jogo pra
questionar repensar e desestruturar
nossos códigos
é um trabalho em progresso de uma
história pessoal para uma história
global e retrato meus voluntários no
fundo branco
depois eu pego um quadradinho de 11 por
11 do nariz pinto o fundo e busco
correspondente na paleta antônio é uma
paleta industrial
eu pensei que o melhor espaço para
mostrar o meu trabalho era internet
porque eu queria um conceito aberto que
vida das pessoas não só apertar o botão
compartilhar no computador
novamente eu comecei com minha família e
meus amigos e depois mais e mais pessoas
se somaram a essa aventura
graças às convocatórias públicas através
das redes sociais
a bola de neve começou a girar e ficou
gigantesca
o projeto teve uma grande aceitação
exposições em galerias museus novas
sessões fotográficas simplesmente
aconteceram e essa é a parte que eu mais
gosto quando o maná e ocupa o espaço
público e aparece nas ruas porque ele
provoca um debate popular cria a
sensação de comunidade e chega
absolutamente todos os públicos
eu retratei mais de três mil voluntários
em 15 países em 24 cidades por todo o
planeta
só pra contar alguns desses exemplos de
alguém que pertence à lista forbes
refugiados que cruzaram o mar
mediterrâneo em um barco em paris na
sede da unesco mas em alojamentos e
estudantes nas favelas do rio de janeiro
os melhores escolas suíças todo tipo de
crença deficiências físicas ou mentais
identidade de gênero desde alguém
recém-nascido alguém com uma doença
terminal todos juntos construímos
humanae esses retratos fazem com que
pensemos como vemos um ao outro quando a
ciência moderna questiona o conceito de
raça o que significa ser preto branco
vermelho e amarelo são os olhos a boca
eo nariz
o cabelo ou será que tem que ver com a
nossa cultura origem nacionalidade
o conta bancária
foi incrível porque conforme o projeto
ea crescendo mais
as pessoas iam dividindo toda essa
experiência comigo e tudo que elas
pensavam sobre o projeto foi muito
especial quando professores começaram a
me inscrever porque elas utilizavam como
ferramenta na sala de aula
o projeto eu vou apresentar alguns essa
é a ana moreira a professora que
inspirada no trabalho criou uma série de
cores chamada isabella ariar na cristina
que são exatamente as cores de cada um
dos alunos que posteriormente faziam
cada um seu retrato
esse é um calendário genial que fez a
dolores o reda que uma professora lá de
élite na espanha porque um dia surgiu
uma polêmica na aula por causa do tal um
lápis cor da pele que só tinha um que as
crianças tinham todas cores diferentes
claro depois de ver todos os professores
fazendo essas coisas incríveis com o
trabalho disse ah eu quero ser
professora também eu vou pra escola
voltei e os meus alunos pintam seu
próprio autorretrato com guache e criam
sua única cor à pele
claro eu só podia atender um grupo
limitado de crianças
então a única maneira de conseguir que
se ficasse grande grande grande era
conquistar mais muito muito mais
professores e fazer com que esses
professores voltassem a ser criança
outra vez
isso já está virando realidade e é
incrível tudo o que acontece eu acho que
todo mundo aqui já fez um exercício de
fazer a impressão da mão e marcar no
papel nethotel o mundo deve ter feito na
verdade a gente faz isso desde a
pré-história teve uma professora que me
mandou essa foto ontem e ela mandou essa
foto com uma mensagem que eu vou lê
o nome dessa professor é este é uma
professora do país basco espanhol
toda a vida fazendo as coisas da mesma
maneira
e olha que agora podemos dar a
oportunidade ao grupo de ver a riqueza
da sua diversidade
eu adoraria e sempre fico pensando eu
adoraria que os meus professores não
tivessem feito as coisas da mesma
maneira
comigo não deu eu lembro quando eu era
pequena e como um dos meus coleguinhas
na escola e disse que não queria brincar
comigo porque eu tinha a cor da merda
mas eu acredito que com a ajuda de vocês
professores e de uma ferramenta como
mannai milhares de crianças em todo o
mundo vão passar pela experiência da cor
da pele de uma maneira diferente
muito obrigada